la magie était de retour à voisins le
bretonneux les apprentis sorciers ont à
nouveau dû déjouer les mystères pour
sauver poudlard bièraubeurre ou potion
pour la deuxième édition des à fred
heroes des le monde de harry potter
était bien présent avec la gazette du
sorcier qui fête ses 20 ans cette année
comme on est complètement bénévole notre
but c'est d'apporter un peu des
animations de de l'expertisé si on parle
avec les fans c'est ça qui est cool
c'est de pouvoir discuter de harry
potter avec avec les gens qui passent et
de montrer le site aussi des sorciers
des mangas des super-héros la pop
culture était représentée sous toutes
les coutures ce week end
j'ai déjà deux artistes qui sont venus
d'eux-mêmes pour exposer au centre avec
une vraie une vraie culture pop culture
les idées fusent et on a beaucoup plus
de soutien de par nos partenaires pour
rassembler les jeunes pour que leur
permettre de s'exprimer de s'amuser sur
deux jours qui leur sont dédiés au
centre un deuxième salon où les codes de
la pop culture étaient présents jusque
dans le concours de cosplay les
organisateurs planchent déjà sur une
troisième édition